c'est dans ce pavillon du quartier des
monte à pain à nevers que s'est déroulé
le drame dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi
la victime un homme de 50 ans poignardée
dans sa chambre pendant son sommeil dès
le lendemain matin le fils de sa
compagne âgée de 18 ans se rend au
commissariat
placé en garde à vue il affirme être
l'auteur des coups de couteau mortels
dans un communiqué le parquet de nevers
indique que l'autopsié a confirmé la
mort par hémorragie massive liées à des
blessures par arme blanche
le procureur précise que selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète le couple
s'était disputé auparavant comme il
aurait l'habitude de le faire
la famille habitait ici depuis plusieurs
années dans le quartier les voisins
restent choqués par les événements mais
confirme un contexte liant alcool et
altercations fréquentent les dimanches
chanuc à 21 heures ils étaient tous là
et sabrina sa comptable m'a fait signe
de s'arrêter ne vient qu'à fait tout est
déjà là à 21 heures j'ai déjà battu avec
son beau-fils de chez mon copain steven
on les entendait souvent se battre
ce soit lui ou est leur meilleur
franchement ça fait drôle hein de savoir
que les voisins qu'on voie relativement
tous les jours on arrive jusque là quoi
le jeune homme et sa mère ont été
présentés hier après midi un juge
d'instruction de bourges de mise en
examen pour homicide volontaire avec
préméditation et complicité d'assassinât
tous les deux ont été placés en
détention à bourges pour la mer et
nevers pour son fils